how about that southwest flight
that's so funny out of it you want to
tell that story go ahead adam this is
adam's favorite story yeah where can i
pull this thing up literally
are we going to talk about this yeah
well we're going to do it right now oh
my god you better bring it out right now
so apparently uh this southwest flight
passenger was very active during this
flight did you have this story in your
backpack
but i'll pull it out
uh so apparently a southwest passenger
arrested for masturbating not once not
twice not thrice
but four times on a on a flight where
was the flight going to uh zenner it was
from seattle to phoenix seattle to
phoenix first of all who the hell is
tracking the four times yeah i want to
know that guy that
was stood behind him and he said
is this a joke or is this real this is a
real story unfortunately from seattle to
phoenix is facing seattle phoenix how
long is that flight two hours maybe it's
probably three hours seattle to phoenix
facing federal charges or pulling down
his pants and masturbating at least four
times in front of a female pastor oh
okay shortly after takeoff
uh antonio sherrod mcgarrity that's his
name he's an irishman right oh my gary
did it again
forgotten mccarrady
[Music]
was arrested by officers at the phoenix
police department when southwest flight
3814 landed at sky harbor international
however mcgarrity told cops that he
didn't do anything wrong and in fact he
was just
thought it was kind of kinky
[Laughter]
started early on the three-hour flight
three-hour play
it says there's a point where he was
doing it for one full hour one hour
if your mask yeah
down below your nose for one second
they're all over you on a plane how did
they not notice this and stop this guy
i'm impressed with four times
it's just
but is this is this like are you like
the the you like the story because it's
like a source of inspiration or whatever
you want to try this you know go for it
but
i think it's a
three-hour flight we're seeing is
wrestling all these
things happen on airplanes these days
well first thing i'd like to see happen
with airlines is to start flying and
landing and taking off on time nice a
lot of playing flights yeah there's been
a lot of delays lately all the people
that are trying to fly in they get late
zetter has such a lot of delays if you
pull your mask down for 30 seconds the
entire plane swarms you and this guy's
beating it for an hour right yeah that's
the craziest thing like you put you take
a sip of your ginger ale you put it back
down and the stew is like put your mask
back over your nose okay i gotta read
this last part this is insane i mean
this guy should be arrested
so amerigarity your irish buddy yeah
good guy massive a good guy good guy
masturbated with his exposed penis in
view of the female passenger on four
separate occasions
uh ambidextrously using both his left
and right hands you know explaining
talent so talented
she suspected that mcgarrity ejaculated
because he licks a white substance from
his fingers what is happening here right
now holy crap what is this tyler why did
you want to address this story this is
how did you watch tyler this was all why
did you want to bring this story up
i don't know i think chris would have
wanted it
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]